oh I'm not thankful for Thanksgiving and
my reason for that you know I know a lot
of people get offended when I say things
like that but my thing is seeking truth
and I feel like in that truth you have
to be honest for what it represents and
it represents you know the killing of a
whole bunch of Native Americans but
people don't like to talk about so my
mission is to bring awareness of that I
can't support the killings of Native
Americans because we all are Native
Americans at the end of the day and I
don't want to hush up about it because
you know I feel like if we do then we're
not waking up our people something I'm
not thankful for this marriage I hated
it it was like the worst two years of my
life I was 21 when I got married my
father figure told me not to because it
would be a mistake and it was thinking
it was so I'm not change before I'm
thankful for the lesson and let's tell
your family first they help you better
than your friends because your friends
ain't gonna be there to see you fall
they're not gonna be that which you
waiting for it's better to let's see you
people that tell you they know what's
best they don't look out for you and I'm
gonna let you did not go to Iran and I'm
gonna tell you my pain-in-the-ass kids
that expect everything in the world and
everything to be done for them without
lifting a finger or sent a scintilla of
gratitude for what you do for them
that's what I'm not thanking for
for the public education system there
you go
school that's because I feel like it
fails more people than it helps really
that's honestly how it go ooh
I'm not thankful for
current relationship is they can be
ending
I hope so honestly I'm not thankful that
there's only 24 hours of the day because
I am in so many internships and have so
many goals to myself and in school and
in work and I want to have fun friends
there's just not enough time in the day
to do it all like I want the fact that I
am 29 years old and I'm still a server
I'll get the thing
I'm leasing
so every year I try to get away from
that next year next Thanksgiving I would
be a career musician I'm not thankful
for being a dog because like I wish I
was a kid again you know like ice cream
truck skateboarding you know all that
not worry in the world I mean the
freedom of being an adult is cool but
the freedom of being a child is even
cooler you know people talk a lot about
tolerance but I don't think tolerance is
as important as understanding I'm not
thankful for I guess the way things are
going right now I wish that everyone
could just get along I know that sounds
so cliche I have a son in the Navy and I
have two sons one is 23 and the others
about to be 20 well I'm black obviously
so both of my sons are black
that's very very scary for a single mom
to know that your your black son is out
there fighting and then at any moment
somebody could just take his life away
without even understanding him or
without even knowing him and then on top
of that my son is gay and he wears
makeup way better than me so there's
just all of this stuff
I just wish I'm not thankful for the way
things are going but I'm still hopeful
prisons people that hate skateboarding I
just think they're bad they're just not
helping humanity but prison lock you up
and throw you away so that's about it
yeah I am NOT thankful for angry
internet trolls that don't know how to
treat people with respect and kindness
and don't know how to be nice and
intelligent people get on there and
they're mean and they tell people to
hurt themselves or call them names
extremely disrespectful and it's
aggravating I'm not thinking for the
hard work I do on the job and on the pay
that I get for the hard work I do and
the warned that don't do the hard work
sit behind a desk get the big pay and
come out with the best and says I'm not
thanking for that I am NOT thankful for
people who forget the reason for the
holiday that's really World War II bar
and that people did have pain F no
houses and yeah I am NOT thankful for
the cold weather because where we live
right now it's really cold and dark and
gray so and on the flipside of that I'm
really grateful to be here in the
sunshine
I'm not thankful for the people that I
work with how about no I'll call on the
beach
Houston Texans losing their star
quarterback I think the people that are
not thankful for the things that they
have or for the things that they achieve
over or the things that they I don't
know that they're giving that God and
people gave us and that they are not
thankful for so
that's my answer so I'm not thankful for
the feeling you get when you wake up
super early there was like you want to
die I'm not thankful for when you have
friends that ask for recommendations and
you take them to a place and they end up
not liking it and they blame you that's
yours
viewers our president don't run I'm not
thankful for Trump Trump I'm not
thankful for Donald Trump have you heard
that a lot I am NOT thankful for liars
and cheaters
there you go I'm not thankful for death
I'm eating deep on the real life stuff a
lot of why I thought you realized that
you want to leave it at that or do you
want to get more specific Oh more
specific I mean so to you I don't care I
guess huh
specifically my dad has cancer and I
hate it that's what I'm not thankful for
not thankful that uh he has to go
through all the suffering
I'm not thankful for the liars but I
guess I am thankful that they taught me
a lesson
I guess was being are not having not
being thankful for something also we did
being thankful for something so it's
like there is no such thing as being not
thankful my guess
[Music]